when we think back on great inventions
of mankind we think about the wheel and
the radio and things like that but we
somehow overlook the simple mirror i
think that no other invention has really
transformed the way that we perceive the
world and more importantly the way that
we perceive
ourselves
daniel rosen has spent a lot of his
career building what he calls mirrors
but they're not what you think
my work centers around the idea of
participation of interaction where the
viewer becomes a part of the piece when
a person stands in front of one of my
art pieces they immediately understand
the interface to it they will see
themselves reflected there's no learning
curve there's no question about what is
the contents of the piece the contents
of the piece is you rosen's made mirrors
from wooden tiles trash fans even pom
poms each meticulously designed built
and programmed to reflect the viewer's
form i remember getting the idea that i
could create a mechanical display by
taking anything and just tilting it up
and down towards or away from the light
just like maybe my hand is doing right
now it is bright when it tilts up it is
dark when it tilts down and i thought i
could take anything and create a display
out of it but making that idea into a
working mirror required a lot of
research practice and patience it was
just out of graduate studies where i
learned how to do some basic electronics
and some programming but definitely i
wasn't prepared to create a complex
piece that required controlling cameras
and moving close to a thousand motors so
i had to go and teach myself how to do
these things
the first project he attempted a tile
mirror with
835 pieces made of pine it was featured
and wired 20 years ago i had to learn
how to fabricate all the wooden tiles
how to move all the motors and how to do
the video capture i start with the
wooden mirror which uses a video camera
and just pixelates what it sees but if
you only have about a thousand pixels
and a person is standing in front of a
noisy background you'll hardly see
anything so i always had to put like a
white wall behind the person which is
not that difficult but if you're trying
to show your art in an office
environment or in a museum that's an
imposition and that was just the first
of many challenges rosen had to overcome
the wooden mirror was made out of 835
servo motors these are cheap and very
easy to control and have a very nice
sound they hum so i was very happy and
used them for quite a few projects over
the first five years of my practice the
problem with several motors is that they
are made of plastic typically and
they're meant to fly you know model
airplanes for 10 minutes they're not
meant to be working 24 hours a day
moving a lot so they fail now he uses
stepper motors which are all metal and
don't have any plastic gears which are
easy to break but they are tougher to
program
some of my newer pieces actually don't
use cameras at all they use motion
sensors or laser sensors to actually
sense the people directly
surprisingly it's the lo-fi aspect of
his projects that are the most difficult
when i first created the wooden mirror
it took me a year to actually build it
i had to cut all the tiles get the
motors learn how to control them so the
electronics and the mechanics and the
fabrication took me a year then it took
me an afternoon to program the computer
to actually activate it
rosen still does everything himself from
designing wiring programming to building
if there is any challenge involved in
these pieces it's the multiplicity if i
do something one i actually usually need
to do it a thousand times so controlling
one motor typically is pretty easy but
wiring and controlling a thousand is
where actually the challenge comes
but rosen doesn't even know if they'll
work until he's finished all the
building all the programming and finally
plugs it in for the first time
you need to actually program a
generative algorithm that will move a
hundred or a thousand pixels to create
that kind of image or animation that's
not always very simple because usually
i'm not doing that on a full computer
i'm programming an arduino board or some
other microcontroller with no graphical
interface and no real way to actually
prototype and see what the result is
going to look like until actually have
it working on the piece itself over the
years he's added in transitions textures
like this effect which he calls blooming
or this one raining
and why has rosen spent years of his
life creating these intricate
installations meticulously cutting
sanding and wiring each piece
the way that we perceive ourselves is in
very stark contrast to the way that
other people see us and when you gaze
into a mirror that divide collapses you
see yourself exactly as other people see
you it's a very emotionally charged
moment and that is a moment that
actually defines a lot of my art the
basic concept for each mirror is similar
but every new material brings unique
challenges i'm interested in this idea
of perception how do we see images in my
mechanical pieces it means chopping up
an image to pixels these pixels are
typically square but they don't have to
be in trash mirror they're just all
kinds of shapes and then i have
sometimes round pixels but they're
always pixels which means there are a
unit of information that can be dark or
bright
in my piece angles mirror i tried a
different approach the piece is made out
of 900 kind of indicators almost like
speedometers in your car that can just
change the angle that they are pointing
so they're not getting brighter or
darker in any way they're not really
pixels and the challenge there was if i
only can change the
rotation orientation of 900 indicators
can i really create an image out of that
and it turns out that the way that our
eyes and our brains see the world are
actually very very sensitive to
orientation so actually by just pointing
to different directions we can
definitely tell apart the foreground the
background a person moving or even
create pretty simple graphics and
animations
his latest project is a commission for
ascap the american society of composers
authors and publishers it's made of wood
and brass materials traditionally used
to make musical instruments as well as
mirrored steel
and rosen's trying something new even
though i've been using the sound and
enjoying the sound of my installations
for many years this is the first time
that i'm actually trying to design the
piece so it will produce sonic output
the piece is made out of 768 tiles of
different materials that can tilt up and
down the little tiles can actually
travel all the way to the end of their
motion and do a little click
and according to the material the wood
the brass or the still they make a
slightly different sound in order to be
able to create faster exchanges i divide
the piece into columns and together they
can hopefully create a much more rapid
staccato or accelerando or any other
kind of musical concept that we're
trying to bring forth
ultimately it's the viewers experience
that drives him to constantly create and
innovate through the medium of mirrors
my pieces are very boring when there's
not a person in front of them if you go
to a gallery and it's empty and you look
at one of my pieces if it's a screen
piece it'll be empty if it's a
interactive mechanical piece it will be
still but the minute a person stands in
front of it it takes your image and i
think that maybe it takes more than your
image that maybe it's capturing
something about your soul and displaying
it back to you
together we are creating the art piece
and the piece would not exist without me
and without the viewer
[Music]